did George Santos lie about his mom
dying in 9 11. this is really really
sick stuff we're talking about
Republican Congressman elect George
Santos elected by the voters of New York
he lied about his employment history he
lied about his educational history he
lied about being Jewish he appears to
have lied about his grandparents being
refugees from the Holocaust he appears
to have lied about so many different
things he is now under criminal
investigation but here is an explosive
new claim
George said this is a mediaite report
George Santos alleged that the 9 11
attacks claimed his mother's life
and five months later said she died in
2016. 15
years after the 9 11 attacks listen to
this yashar Ali flagged these tweets
from 2021 last night
these appear to be contradictory claims
to say the least on July 12th of 2021
George Santos tweeted 911 claimed my
mother's life
9 11 claimed my mother's life
five months later in December of 2021
he said his mom died in December of 2016
which is
15 years and two months after 9 11.
December this is his tweet December 23rd
this year marks five years I lost my
best friend and Mentor mom you will live
forever in my heart
Santos campaign website States quote
George's mother was in her office in the
South Tower on 9 11 2001 when the
horrific events of that day unfolded she
survived the tragic events on 9 11 but
passed away a few years later when she
lost her battle to cancer
anybody have any idea what's going on
here because I certainly don't and the
article writes although many at Ground
Zero in the aftermath developed health
problems like cancer
15 years is not a few years later
so what of this is true I have no idea
as a reminder media I reminds us Santos
also claimed he lost four employees in
the 2016 Pulse Nightclub shooting in
Orlando however none of the 49 people
killed are linked to any of the places
that he even claimed to have worked
which is a whole other story I don't
know what the truth is but it is natural
to be extraordinarily skeptical given
the disgusting nature of this guy's lies
now is he ultimately going to going to
be forced into resignation I don't know
we're running out of time
um I believe he should be he has shown a
willingness to lie for what he believes
to be personal gain but also even if you
want to argue or suggest that there are
other motivations like for example he's
just a pathological liar there are
people who it's almost reflexive they
just lie they lie they lie they lie you
know I I I've told a couple stories I
was reminded of another person I know
where it it was like a reflex it was
quite literally a reflex and I remember
having a conversation with them where I
said oh yeah you know um like at the
time we were I think we were using
Constant Contact for email where I go
yeah we um we use a service called
Constant Contact for email they're
actually uh
um you know they're pretty good or
something and the person said oh yeah my
uncle works at Constant Contact and I
said oh really because Constant Contact
space like in the Boston suburbs I
didn't know you had a you're like oh no
well yeah he works remotely for them oh
huh it wasn't true just just it's
natural natural instinct to just lie lie
lie if that's part of what is going on
here with George Santos that also
doesn't make no particularly good
candidate to be a member of the House of
Representatives so we'll see what
happens in the next couple days the
pressure to resign is mounting uh the
criminal probe is a real problem at this
point and that may be what pushes him
over the edge into resignation but at
the same time
he may be one of 435 members of Congress
starting next week which would be yet
another embarrassment and humiliation
for the United States not to the degree
of trump being president certainly but
it will certainly be a humiliation we're
going to try to get him on the show
I would love for him to tell us in his
own words what all of this is about I
don't know that he's going to accept
that invitation
when you're working during the day when
you're on the go and you're in the mood
for something sweet don't reach for the
candy bar go for something that's just
as good but without the sugar and carbs
our sponsor monk pack makes delicious
keto granola bars and nut and Seed bars
they're tasty crunchy gooey sweet and
salty I love them but each bar has only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and about 150 calories perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb or low sugar you
can have a treat that feels indulgent
and satisfying without the guilt monk
pack comes in flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate caramel sea salt they just
launched two new flavors I love peanut
butter cocoa chip and dark chocolate
cocoa my favorite thing is the texture
I've tried a lot of these nut bars
granola bars monk pack is superior if
you don't agree you get your money back
and it is the perfect holiday gift go to
monkpak.com and get 20 off your first
order with the code Pacman the link is
down below